Pan Out.
I had a similar idea.
Anthony Kumina were alive,
sir. I love it. Joe Rogan.
If it was not for you, oh
my God, this, this would not
exist. That which is insane.
That is 100% actual fact.
I was watching you doing live from
the compound. Me and Brian Red Band.
We're sitting in my fucking living
room and we were watching you.
You were fucking playing karaoke.
You're singing karaoke with a machine gun
in front of a green screen. I was like,
this guy,
this guy just set up his own studio like
he already has opie and Anthony show.
At the time you guys were at Sirius Xm
and he just decided to do this thing and
your basement just for a goof.
Yeah. It was like a hobby,
but it's like guys who don't have kids,
married, not married, don't have kids,
so I have anybody telling them what to
do and they also have disposable income.
Then you get to see what
guys really want to do.
They want to sing karaoke with a machine
gun in front of a green screen. Yeah.
It was crazy. Crazy gun guy.
Karaoke, so I could do that.
If I was married, I would have a wife that
would lose her mind at my living room.
My living room table that you're
supposed to have a candle on and little
chotchkies and stuff is a widescreen,
a computer monitor and a gaming
system right next to the table.
I have a gaming computer that's just
unbelievable and I sit there and just play
video games. So the table itself is a
gaming monitor? Yeah, the whole tape.
Well it's one of those touch screen ones.
No, it's, it's a giant wide monitor.
It's like a like 40 inches wide. So
that's the table? No, it's on the table.
The table is big, heavy metal
thing, but it's just everything.
There's VR goggles up on
the console by the TV.
It's just a sensors around
the room for the VR.
It's a playground and
you're absolutely right.
Guys will spend their
money on having fun if,
if allowed to. That's what this place is.
This place is insane. Joe's in my house.
You go to my house, it's my wife's
house. Say That's how it works.
I have one elk head on the wall. That's
all I have. That's all you're allowed.
I laugh at guys and they have
the, uh, the man cave. Like, dude,
come on down to the man cave. The chicks
aren't allowed down here. I got this,
the TV that, and I'm like, no
horror places. The whole house.
She relegated you to one room
and go and you're happy about it.
You're happy that you got one
room. Happy wife, happy life.
That's apparently it didn't work.
It didn't work for me.
You know that the row quote that I say
way too many times in this podcast,
but I love the quote. Most men live
lives of silent desperation. Wow.
Yeah, that is true. It's
100% true. It was, uh,
I was married for a time and it was a,
it was a nightmare.
It was a living hell for me.
The only thing that got me through
as many years as I was married,
because I was married nine years and
I don't remember one happy year out of
those nine,
but I had gotten into radio pretty
early on in that marriage. Um,
and that was my life.
So I dedicated myself no matter how
miserable anything else in my life was.
I was doing radio, so I thought it was
awesome. I have a theory about that.
I really do.
I think that a person needs a certain
amount of suffering in their life.
And if you look at some of
the all time great comics, oh,
or even all time great radio
personalities, like Howard Stern,
Howard stern during his
hay day when he was,
the fucking man was miserable. Right?
Right. And he would talk about it.
He would hide in his basement. I
love those stories. You realize like,
here's this guy. He's the, you know, the
biggest radio personality ever. He's,
he's huge.
And yet he's got to hide and,
and he's just talking about masturbating
and hiding from his wife and you can't
get any sex. And you'll like,
it didn't matter if he was huge.
It didn't matter if he was famous. Didn't
matter how Richie was, it didn't matter.
He's just hiding in the basement.
And that anx came out on the radio like
you related to him. You understood it.
Yeah. Yeah. I get that. Um,
and it worked for me because there was
a lot of misery. Like when I started,
uh, doing really well, we
moved back to New York from,
from Boston after we got fired.
[inaudible] opiod myself.
You guys got fired for saying
that the mayor died? Yeah,
it was an April fool's gag. And,
uh, because we always thought the,
the radio April fool's jokes were
so stupid and Hokey and uh, yeah,
we changed the format to all Elvis and
it's like after 10 minutes they say April
fools.
So we're like,
let's just go balls out and
say the mayor's dead and
to have a news guy come on
and report it and everything.
And then it was supposed to subsequently
get more outrageous as the, uh,
the show went on. So by the
end of it, there was a, uh,
Taiwan male hooker in the car with them
and they crashed because he was getting
a blow job or stuff like it was
going to get really ridiculous,
but they stopped it early on and
never allowed us to even mention it.
So people really thought he died.
Although it's kind of stupid.
You go to the ONA show for your news,
but back then the internet wasn't
what it is now. Exactly. Yeah.
Dinner was it even it was barely a
thing. It was barely a thing. Uh,
cause that was 90, 97 around there. 98.
What year did you get on? You'll
probably early. I was on really early,
like the 80s. I was on bulletin
boards servers, uh, and uh,
used to play Trivia Games with
a 300 baud modem with people.
And I thought it was amazing. Uh,
even then and then in, in the, uh,
when we were up in Boston,
I bought a digital camera that
was just this giant thing.
And I had a laptop and
other giant thing and uh,
I would take pictures of what was going
on in the studio and then post them that
night on a website that I figured out.
I used to code the html myself and make
a website just to post pictures and
links and people thought it was amazing.
Like you're seeing what we talked
about that day. Uh, it wasn't instant,
but it was pretty cold. And then I started
doing videos. I was able to put video,
like maybe eight second clips of nude
girls if they were in the studio and pop
that up and people loved it. Uh,
and then I got a bill from the,
the company for bandwidth
and I didn't know bandwidth.
It was a $12,000 bill for a
month. Yeah. Yeah. Cause I,
there was no,
there was no compression or anything.
I'm pumping video out to thousands
of people on compressed. And uh,
apparently, um, they had that happen
a couple of times. So they told me
just don't do it again. They didn't
make me pay, which was pretty cool.
But at that point I had to learn about,
you know,
coding and a compression
and things like that.
So you just kept doing it and just,
just put them in some sort of a
compressed format. Yeah. Would you use,
do you remember back then? Oh God,
I think it was like a for audio.
It was real audio, which was hilarious.
Right. The little player, he'll play it.
Real audio player would pop
up. And then for video, God,
I can't even remember what it was, but
it was terrible. It was all pixelated,
you know, like 10 frames per minute and
kind of weird to things like real audio,
which was everywhere.
Just they just quit.
Then they gave up around
still, unless they changed
into something else, you know,
or kind of got bought out by somebody up.
Yeah, yeah. That's happens to everything.
But honestly,
if it was not for you and your show
live from the competent and for opiate,
hilarious because opie and Anthony was
the first radio show that I re what are
wherever realize you don't
really have to have a format.